In this first, what I'll call
this is my first real linear
algebra video, I want to
introduce you to some concepts
that you're going to see over
and over in linear algebra,
and if they're not introduced
to you properly in the
beginning, they can
be very confusing.
But hopefully over the course
of this video, you'll
understand that they're pretty
straightforward ideas.
If anything, in linear algebra,
the field, or the
gods of linear algebra, are
kind of experts in to some
degree stating simple and
obvious things in convoluted
and Byzantine ways.
But it does that for a
reason; it gives it
mathematical rigor.
So the first thing I want to
introduce you to is the set
notation for real numbers and
then multiple dimensions of
real numbers.
So if you ever see this, an R
with an extra backbone like
that, or sometimes it's written
as just a really
bold-faced R if it's maybe
typed in a book, a really
bold-faced R, this just means,
the set of all real numbers.
And I probably should make a
few videos where I classify
numbers by reals and complex
and irrational and rational
and whatever else, and there's
actually very formal ways of
defining the set of all real
numbers, but the simple thing
for me is all numbers
except complex ones.
So this is the same thing as
everything but complex numbers.
So pi is a real number, e is a
real number, square root of 2
is a real number, 3 is a real
number, minus 3 is a real
number, minus pi is a real
number, But 1 plus 2i is not a
real number.
It's not in the set of reals;
that's a complex number.
So everything but complex.
So pretty much all regular
numbers that you ever dealt
with before you learned
what i was.
That's the set of
real numbers.
Now, the next thing you'll see
when you start discussing
linear algebra is someone will
write-- they won't just write
the set of all real numbers,
they'll write Rn.
And you're like, gee,
what is that?
Are they somehow taking
the exponent of
all of the real numbers?
And actually on some level, that
is what they're doing,
but what they're saying here is
they're taking the set of
all ordered sets of
real numbers.
So what do I mean by that?
So let me do an example where
I don't just have Rn,
So R2 is the set of all lists
of real numbers, and let me
make one of the lists.
So let's say this has
one number and then
it has another number.
So it's the set of -- let me
write it this way, so I can
write in the set of notations.
It's the set of all-- we could
call these tuples.
Sometimes it's called a 2-tuple,
which just means a
list of two numbers.
That's all it means.
It just means a list
of two numbers.
So R2 is a list of all ordered
2-tuples, so all ordered lists
of two numbers.
Let me actually write down the
word ordered because that's
important, so ordered
list of 2-tuples.
So, for example, this would
be-- well, let me
write it this way.
This would be a different-- when
I say ordered, I'm saying
that this is fundamentally
different than that, that
these aren't the same 2-tuple.
Each of these is a 2-tuple,
but R2 is a set of all
2-tuples such that-- that line
there just means such that or
maybe for which-- each of
the numbers-- and I'll
write it this way.
I could just write-- well, I
could write it a couple of
ways, but I'll write it in the
harder to understand way, just
so you get used to it.
Such that xi is a member
of the reals.
So member of, that's what this
little character means.
So that each xi is a member
of the reals.
So what do you you mean xi?
Well, xi just means any of these
x's, and I'll write for
i is less than or equal to 2 and
greater than or equal to
1, and i is an integer.
Now, I could have written this
a bunch of different ways.
This is almost silly how much
effort I'm taking to write it
this way, but I could have
written it like this, too.
I could have written that R2
is equal to the set of all
ordered tuples, x1 x2 such
that-- I could have just
written such that x1 and x2
are a member of the reals.
I could have written
it that way.
That would have been an easier
way to write it.
But either way, I think
you get the idea.
It's all of the combinations
of two things.
So I said in the beginning,
this kind of is a squared
operator. and why do
they write it as
a superscript there?
And my gut sense is if you think
about it, you have an
infinite number of
real numbers.
I won't go into things like
accountability and things like
that, but you have a very large
number of real numbers.
But let's say that you only
had n real numbers, right?
Let's say that we weren't
dealing with reals.
Just for sake of argument, let's
say that you had like
100 real numbers, right?
So that means that there
would've been 100
possibilities there, and then
there's another 100
possibilities there.
So now your set of all the
possibilities of 2-tuples,
well, you'd have 100 times 100
possibilities, so you'd almost
have the squared number
of possibilities.
So however many possibilities
you have for R, you have that
many squared possibilities for
R2, which doesn't make a lot
of sense, because you have
an infinite number of
possibilities, but you have that
many more possibilities.
You have an infinite number of
possibilities here and an
infinite number of possibilities
here.
So it's almost a greater
infinity of potential
possibilities.
Now, what's R3?
R3 is just the same thing.
R3 means you're going to have
three points or three numbers.
I want to be careful not
to just say points.
We can graph these things, and,
for example, R2, point in
R2 can normally be graphed on
graph paper just in Cartesian
coordinates.
Points in R3 can be graphed
in three dimensions.
Points in just R, or we could
just say R1, you could just
graph those on a number line.
I can have a number line like
that, and if I had to graph
pi, you know, that's 0.
I just say, hey, right
there, that's pi.
And if i had to graph e,
I'd say, hey, right
there, that's e.
And if I had to graph 1,
I'd say, hey, that's 1.
So you could graph them, but
I want to be careful.
You don't have to graph them.
They don't have to correspond
to actual
physical points on a graph.
But anyway, when you talk about
R3, you're literally
just talking about all the
possibilities where you have
an ordered set of three numbers,
where all three
numbers are a member of
the real numbers.
That's all you're saying.
Now, I want to introduce
you to another
definition of a vector.
Now, a vector, you've
seen before.
You've seen it in physics,
where you said, oh, it's
something that has a magnitude
and a direction.
You saw it in calculus, and we
plotted them and whatever not.
But I'm going to be very formal
and very abstract and
very broad with the vector right
now because the beauty
of linear algebra is that it
doesn't just apply to things
like physics, and it doesn't
just apply-- well, it does
apply a lot to physics, but it
doesn't just apply to that.
In linear algebra, you can
apply it to anything.
It doesn't have to apply to
things that just graphs in
three dimensions.
And we'll talk more about that
in the future, but that's why
I'm trying to stay
pretty abstract.
So I'm going to define
a vector in Rn, a
vector to be in Rn.
Actually, let me be careful.
I haven't even defined
what Rn is.
I just defined R2 and R3,
so let me define Rn.
Rn is equal to the set of all
n-tuples, ordered n-tuples.
So you have x1, x2, all
the way over to xn.
So you're going to have n
things; so if this was 100,
you'd have 100 things here.
So this is an ordered n-tuple.
This is an ordered n-tuple, such
that for each xi, where
xi is one of these, it is a
member of the real, so each of
these has to be a real number.
And then I'll just say for i
is less than or equal to n,
greater than or equal to 1.
So all that's saying is that x1
is a member of the reals,
x2 is a member of the reals,
all the way up to xn is a
member of the reals.
Rn is the set of all of these
possible ordered n-tuples or
ordered sets of n numbers.
So what is a vector?
What is a vector in Rn?
Well, a vector in Rn really is
just a particular instance of
one of these n-tuples.
I'll just call it an ordered
list of n real numbers.
And you can represent a vector
in a bunch of different ways.
You could represent
it like this.
You could represent it like--
let me do it a bunch of
different ways.
A two-dimensional vector, you
could represent like x1, x2,
kind of like a coordinate.
You could maybe represent it
with brackets like that.
This is just syntax.
This is just different ways
of representing the same
information, the same idea.
And for most of what we talk
about in linear algebra, we're
going to represent them as
essentially these columns, and
in the very near future,
we'll represent
them as rows as well.
But I'm going to define
my vector.
A vector as an Rn is an
ordered list of n real
numbers, and I define-- and
this is an example.
So it would be v1, v2, all the
way to vn, where each of these
is a member of the
real numbers.
And just to make sure you
understand the notation or the
terminology, each of
these is called a
component of our vector.
Actually, I want to be very
careful here, because when we
write vectors, you want
to make sure you
have a nice bold v.
I won't make all my v's in the
future that bold, but that's
how, when you're reading a math
book, they differentiate
between just a vector and just
a regular quantity , right?
These regular quantities are
just written non-bolded, while
the vectors are bolded.
Now, I'm going to define two
operations for vectors in Rn.
I'm going to define addition,
and these are definitions.
I could've defined them in any
arbitrary way, but these I
think you'll find to be somewhat
natural, so these are
definitions.
These are just human abstract
constructs that end up
becoming very useful.
So they said, hey, let's
make some definitions.
Let's define addition.
So, if I have some vector-- let
me write it as a lowercase
a, but it's a really bolded
lowercase a, and then that is
equal to a1, a2.
That's all of it's components
all the way to an, and I want
to add that.
And then I have vector b-- and
I'm going to make that a
really bolded b right there--
is equal to b1, b2, all the
way to bn, I'm going to define
addition of these two vectors
to be just the sum of each
of their components.
Bolded a, plus bolded b is equal
to a new vector, where
you just add each of
their components.
It's going to be a1 plus
b1 is going to
create this new component.
a2 plus b2, all the way
down to an plus bn.
And if you found this somewhat
confusing, just think, I'm
almost going through pains to
write something very simple in
very confusing terms. If I have
two vectors in R2, let's
say I have the vector 2, minus
1, and I want to add that to
the vector 3, 2, I literally
just add each of the
corresponding components.
So I add the first components
to each other.
So 2 plus 3 is equal to 5.
Minus 1 plus 2 is equal to 1.
That's all my definition of
vector addition is for my
vectors in real numbers.
And now the next thing I'm going
to define is the idea of
a scalar multiple.
You might remember from physics
class, a scalar is
just a regular number, or if
your multiplying something by
a scalar, you're just
scaling it up.
Maybe I shouldn't use the same
word in the definition, but
I'm going to define it as--
let me say c is a scalar.
So notice, I didn't
bold the c.
So c times my vector a-- and
here I'm going to take pains
to bold it up-- is going to be
equal to all of my components
of vector a multiplied by
each, multiplied by c.
So a1, a2, all the way to an,
and they're each going to be
multiplied by c.
So that's all I define-- every
term is going to be
multiplied by c.
And just to give you an example
like that, if I wrote
minus 3 times some vector--
I'll just
draw the vector here.
Let me draw a vector in R3.
So let's say the first term is
pi, the second term is minus
2, and then the third term is 0,
then this is just going to
be equal to a new vector in R3
or you can kind of view it as
a three-dimensional vector,
minus 3pi, minus 3 times minus
2 is positive 6, and then minus
3 times 0 is just 0.
So it's that straightforward.
They made this fancy definition,
but it's fairly
easy to deal with, I think.
And I'll just make one last
definition, and I'll call that
the zero vector.
And depending on what dimension
we're in, it just
means a vector with
all zeroes.
So the zero vector in Rn, if
it's arbitrary, is just a
vector where everything
is zero.
And if this is Rn, you just
have n components.
So those are all
my definitions.
I think I've given you enough
to think about right now in
this video.
In the next video, I'm going
to show a bunch more of
examples, and I'll actually draw
representations of these
vectors, although you don't
have to, and we'll kind of
have a little more visual
understanding
of what they mean.